[Music]
in the beginning
there was nothing
well
except for you
and the big bang
[Music]
what would the first moments of the
universe be like
what would happen over the next
thousands of years
and
would anyone believe you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were alive during the big
bang what's the last dumpling ah the big
bang theory
no not the tv show
i'm talking about the most popular story
about the earliest moments in the
history of the universe
according to this theory the universe
emerged from a single point nearly 14
billion years ago
this point known as a singularity
would have been infinitely dense
from this singularity the entire
universe expanded
eventually cooling down enough to form
stars
galaxies and planets like the one you
are on now
and our universe is still expanding
today
that's one of the most compelling pieces
of evidence supporting the big bang
theory
so
let's travel back to a time where it all
began
but before we take this trip in our
spaceship we need to get some food
together you don't want to be eating
dehydrated food every day out here well
that's why i use factor
factor delivers fresh never frozen meals
created by a team of gourmet chefs and
each meal is ready to go within minutes
there's no prep and no mess it's just
heat eat and enjoy you know in this cold
weather i love the spicy turkey poblano
bowl
anything with poblano peppers and
anything called spicy is right up my
alley and factor even lets me craft my
future orders from my taste preferences
and my meal history with more than 27
meals and 33 add-on options every week
there's something for everyone no matter
what diet you're on
head to go.factor75.com
what if 120 and use the code what if 120
to get
120 off
that's go go.factor75.com
whatif120 code whatif120 to start
claiming your time back while still
eating healthy
you know you better stock up this time
machine now because we're not going to
see another kitchen for billions of
years
set your coordinates to 13.82
billion years ago
time to take your shiny new time machine
on an epic spin into the past
what you'd find when you arrived would
be
well
nothing
you and everything you've ever known
no longer exist
but by some miracle of your time machine
spaceship
you'd arrive at the exact moment of the
big bang
before this moment
all the particles that make up the
universe were crammed so tightly that
not one atom could even form
in this state the density was infinitely
higher than the matter in our current
universe
right after the big bang occurred
this matter existed in the form of quark
gluon plasma or
qgp
very quickly in a matter of milliseconds
the particles making up this qgp
would clump together to form the protons
and neutrons that make up the atoms we
know today
according to astrophysicist paul sutter
at this point everything was crushed
into a ball about the size of a peach
this ball would have been very hot
how hot
oh only like a trillion kelvin
that's like
999 billion degrees celsius
and i wouldn't blink if i were you
because if you did you'd miss the
universe rapidly inflating from the size
of a basketball
to roughly the size of the sun
particles would be flying through the
qgp at velocities higher than the speed
of sound
like a jet traveling at mach speed
these particles would emit a supersonic
boom
of course you wouldn't hear anything
sound can't travel through the vacuum of
space
not to mention you'd be witnessing a
time before any matter has formed
and sorry to say you'd barely be able to
see anything either
everything would look foggy and blurry
the super dense plasma would scatter
light similar to water droplets in
clouds
one micro second after the big bang
you'd see neutrinos quarks and electrons
form
shortly after that you'd see protons and
neutrons forming
this would all be happening within one
second
at this point the temperature of
everything would have dropped to a
chilly 5.5 billion degrees celsius
and after about three minutes
things would have cooled down enough for
these protons and neutrons to form
hydrogen nuclei
you'd now be witnessing the era of
nucleosynthesis
but don't get ahead of yourself
you wouldn't see the first elements form
for
another 380 000 years
all those years later the universe has
finally expanded and cooled enough for
electrons to stay in orbit around an
atomic nuclei
the first hydrogen and helium atoms
would form you'd finally be able to see
things more clearly too
okay now you've reached the point in our
creation timeline that scientists have
some evidence of today
cosmic microwave background radiation or
cmb
is leftover radiation from about 400 000
years after the big bang
these microwaves are invisible to the
naked eye but they reveal that there was
a time when the universe was both hotter
and denser
more proof that scientists point to in
favor of this history of the universe is
the speed that galaxies appear to be
moving away from us
faster than those closer to us
this would suggest that there was a time
when all galaxies were in the same spot
yeah the singularity
of course you would have witnessed all
this firsthand but
without bringing back any definitive
proof
the big bang would still remain a
theoretical model of the history of the
universe
there would still be so many unanswered
question and even if it was all true
would that really have been the
beginning of
everything well
that's a story
for another
what if